[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the impeachment trial
continues in the senate pictures right
behind me the president by the way
speaking tonight at a rally in the state
of Iowa the caucus is there the first
contest of the Democratic nominating
process started just a few days so
that'll be interesting of course we'll
bring you highlights of that as we
always do so for the last week we've
been watching a list and some of the
more cynical among us have dismissed the
impeachment trial as a hollow political
stunt it's something like a network
entertainment division must have cooked
up they say it's a bad reality show
well we're traditional is here so we've
resisted that view what this is really
about and we told you this last night is
foreign policy it's about Ukraine that
noble windswept Eastern European nation
that is our single greatest ally in the
world may be our only real Ally if
Ukraine wants it we provided that's the
rule as they've explained in the Senate
all decent Americans stand with Ukraine
now for a moment the president seemed to
falter in his moral duty to stand with
Ukraine and for that he's being
impeached
so impeach what is a very serious thing
Ukraine depends on it
that was our conclusion yesterday but
Minds change we saw this this is an
exchange between the president's lawyer
eminent Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz and a pair of little-known
but clearly accomplished Democratic
lawmakers senator Goldberg of New Jersey
and Senator Behar of New York now we
don't want to belittle the process here
but honestly what you're about to see
does seem a shade theatrical for
something as serious as an impeachment
trial but judge for yourself according
to what I'm reading you're the only
constitutional scholar who goes with
that line there is not one other who
agrees with you not why let me be very
clear about that in 1867 the Dean of the
Columbia Law School
listen I need to have these just to move
on so you you're not gonna get me to
move on until I make this point okay any
time because you got four people trying
to ask you questions faster I have wait
how did senator goldberg wind up on
Christopher Columbus sailing the ocean
blue Columbus never even went to Ukraine
so far as we know and for there she
attacked Abraham Lincoln who also never
went to Ukraine some that we seem to
have lost the thread here the reasoning
was getting hard to follow and then into
this roiling bully obeys of confusion
jump senator Hostin at the Upper West
Side a lawmaker justly famous for the
windowpane clarity of her legal analysis
watch her reframe the debate but let me
ask you this very quickly just sure just
for giggles what if the president spent
the year vacationing in Moscow changed
the language of this country perhaps to
Russian or decided to stop doing his job
entirely and perhaps golf all day he
does that you're saying we don't know
grounds to impeach him is a crime either
and so the list of charges against the
president grew longer not only did
Donald Trump ask unauthorized questions
about how hunter Biden makes a living
and that's not allowed he's also
apparently living in Putin's Russia and
planning on switching our nation's
alphabet to cyrillic so those letters
don't even look real they're like
astrological signs this is a major
development but are those impeachable
offenses oh you bet they are
and speaking of bedding here's how the
hearing ended with a high-stakes wager
the GAO an independent watchdog said
last week that withholding the aid to
Ukraine was illegal no they don't say
that they said no no Sonny
[Music]
[Applause]
$3000 yes let's bet $1,000 to be
contributed to the Peace of Israel and
Palestine please we got to pause here
for a quick correction apparently
there's some sort of unfortunate mix-up
in our tape library before the show and
some of the video you just saw I guess
all the video our producers are saying
was not in fact from today's Senate
impeachment trial those are not actual
US senators though of course the easily
could be there instead hosts on a
daytime chat show over on ABC called the
view who they despised the president
they seemed entirely sincere about that
but like so many of the people who are
running and commenting on this
impeachment trial they seem to have no
idea what it's actually about they don't
understand the charges they know nothing
about the historical precedent facts and
details are irrelevant to them they
didn't even bother to read the GAO
report that they introduced as evidence
they got a backward not that it slowed
them down or ever does they are lazy and
silly and wrong but at the same time
they are utterly certain they're on the
morally correct side of history they
know they're good people
excellent people actually unlike that
horrible old orange man who speaks
Russian and the rubes who voted for him
they know all of that for certain so in
their view they've got the big things
totally right and that's all that
matters and so in that way despite the
tape mix-up it really could have been
the impeachment trial it's essentially
the same thing